the Environmental Protection Agency
accidentally released is you all read
about this three million gallons of
polluted water from an abandoned gold
mine
in the Animas River now the river is
full of pollutants now like arsenic
mercury and the entire river has turned
yellow it's been in all the papers yeah
it's a huge environmental disaster
there's no word yet on when this will
all get cleaned up
but until then one local company has
decided to make the most out of the
situation check it out youth boost
50-foot Falls without breaking a sweat
you can shoot the gnarliest rapids with
one dick tied behind your back
but have you never kayaked in a river
where the water is literally trying to
kill you you will the Colorado
natural disaster ultimate river rapids
extreme kayaking adrenaline venture
tours LLC thanks to a wicked assist from
the EPA Colorado's Animas River is now
pure liquid poison
and it's yours for the taking bro to
grab your paddle and get your affairs in
order
then shoot through over 30 miles of
arsenic laced mustard-colored dude juice
and if the river doesn't kill you though
recently mutated aquatic life will avoid
shiet minnows lavatory and frogs with
human feed so bring your bros and meet
with our lawyers then gear up and ride
the muster it's a wet and wild adventure
you'll never forget just ask one of our
satisfied customers
the Colorado natural disaster ultimate
river rapids extreme kayaking adrenaline
venture tours LLC get ready for the last
ride of your life
[Applause]
hey thanks for watching please subscribe
to my youtube channel so they will stop
making me shoot these videos please